if you could be a professional athlete
in any other sport which would be
today's will be tennis or badminton
maybe table tennis table tennis probably
a cricketer because ice skating
basketball I really love basketball
basketball if you could Master any
musical instrument immediately what
wouldn't be the drums
okay we had to say pianos I am also
going with that
novel guitar actually violin what's your
go-to karaoke songs
but I only sing in the shower or when
nobody can hear me they're too good with
reactions
if you could eat only one food item for
the rest of your life water and easy
chicken and rice fried rice
kids